Manila Luzon is here it's tonight and I
still entertaining so you're in the
right place I'm in the right place and
you're back on our TV screens all stars
for all stars for RuPaul's Drag Race on
vh1 for the first time in drag race
history all star rules are suspended
until further notice
and All Stars rules are suspended what
does that mean ah I don't even really
know if I can tell you like without
giving anything away the drama is like
back gia guns back and she just had a
big old spoon with a rhinestone spoon
and she just likes stirring the pot a
lot of girls gets to have like a little
bit of that moment where they get to
confront the girl who sent them home you
know I'd love to congratulate Valentina
because she got to have you know her
when and she got this in pheromone home
I'm glad she gets to have that this you
are bitter bitter is a really strong
word usually they bring back one girl
but now they brought back all the girls
and it was just like oh my god we're at
the same spot we like started out I feel
like we have gone nowhere it's like
riding a fricken treadmill let's talk
about the Queen's on All Stars for I
want to reopen the library oh my god and
do some rapid fire reads
[Music]
oh gosh I want them to be really good
because I just don't get the opportunity
to read these [ __ ] TV very often all
right let's do this all right let's
start with gonna exchange ooh money
exchange her voice is so high Mariah
Carey has has put a hit out on her yeah
done oh gosh she's oh it's so up there
that high rate like it just it makes me
feel like I have like a low base like
man when I talk next to her wait was
that a brief ago now Monique Oh was that
for a Monet oh I'm God there you go that
was my read I got season two [ __ ]
okay thank you everybody mix them up I
mixed them up oh my god it's a benefice
Naomi smalls
she's legs for days lips for years and
she has the eyebrows that like go behind
her ears like a pair of oakley
sunglasses right sometimes she put the
wig on it's just like oh wait let me
just erase this I like her I don't think
you looked at a human face in a while
that's speaking of big lips try kneading
it Chuck yes um I don't know how she
manages to tuck her I feel really bad
her nutsack I really do it just must be
like goo gone its adhesive remover like
for like hours after no Trinity is
chilliest IVA she's proud of all the
stuff that she's pumped into her face
honey and it's a lot yeah it's just put
a lot of things in her face
Valentina Valentina I love Valentina
because like you know being a drag queen
you have you have to straddle the line
between reality and fantasy you know she
is full right she's all the way over
here there is no like this time you know
like a window to to reality in her world
fire could be raining down like a whole
zombie apocalypse could be happening and
this thing would be still getting ready
like slowly painting on her eye makeup
like being like there's not a care in
the world
I am beautiful there's like people
screaming and fire like it's exploding
yeah she is in her own world ladies I'm
boiling
my blood is simmering through my veins
and I have some things to say okay I am
deeply and utterly offended Latrice
Royale
see I don't want to say anything bad
about her because I was like boo-hooing
so much when she got sent home my best
friend's know I am excited to see what's
going on with her because I know from
she stuff of a very kind person but I'm
gonna get her mad honey okay let's race
you guys are used to Fame
I'm excited to see y'all guys watch her
Throwdown gia Gunn
oh my gosh
gia Gunn it was so bad at snatch game I
hope I find rav4 right so no more doing
nails for me you know what now she's
back with that big spoon pheromone Oh
pheromone I honestly first like I don't
even know how to read her because it's
like you don't even have to all I know
is that self-tanner girl it's it's a lot
it's a lot of self tanner but she likes
to Sparkle like she's like one of those
vampires in the Twilight disease
planet Jasmine masters jazz and master
of the judge herself yeah we didn't get
to see a lot of her it's really hard
seeing her you know a lot like you know
all the time so you're not getting the
full version of messages okay maybe
maybe this she's not meant for the show
because she can't be the full messages
on the show yeah but definitely watch
her it's a girl lives I you know
whatever I have a little notification
whenever Jeff masters goes on live to
wrap things up here what's gonna
surprise us about what's still to come
it all starts for I think the biggest
surprise is going to be that immediately
following the episode we're gonna go
straight into Cecil again and so you're
gonna forget about us completely
[Music]